mais qu'est ce qu'ils ont fabriqué ici
c'est grave non pas trop mais c'est
difficile à dire le camion s'enfonce de
plus en plus là il soulève le camion
pour glisser des pierres en dessous
l'arbre ou pas il n'y a pas d'autre
solution pour sortir de là
lourdement chargés en vivres et en
hommes ce camion s'embourbe lentement
depuis le début de la matinée
tant bien que mal les passagers tentent
d'en dégager les routes comment ça se
passe par là dépêchez vous avec la pluie
on s'enfonce de plus en plus dingoo et
perd patience
il faut qu'il se bouge là et décide de
prendre les choses en main occupes toi
de la roue et arrête de creuser ici ça
sert à rien comment maintenant il faut
plus de pierre ding dirige donne des
ordres mais ne veut pas se salir les
mains
pas question de porter une pierre arrête
il va pleuvoir
c'a été un faux essayer de repartir
maintenant j'espère qu'on va y arriver
allez on va tous poussés
les pieds dans la boue le visage dans le
pot d'échappement les passagers sans
courage
[Musique]
les maisons
allez allez tous au camion on reprend la
route
[Applaudissements]
ding wen connaît bien les aléas de ce
genre de piste il les a pratiqué pendant
de nombreuses années
quand j'avais 15 ans j'étais camionneurs
et tu transporté quoi exactement
j'allais chercher le bois et le granit
dans la montagne près de chez moi
et conduire un camion sur ce genre de
route c'est bien plus difficile que le
cadre g a déjà eu de gros problèmes ah
oui une fois j'ai eu un accident
le volant de mon camion était mal réparé
il s'est bloqué et mon camion s'est
renversé
heureusement j'ai pas été blessé j'ai
réussi à sortir par la porte passager
mais c'est fini maintenant l'avis de
chauffeur
ainsi encore un problème on va encore
perdre du temps les pluies diluviennes
de ces derniers jours ont emporté un pan
de la colline qui s'est effondré sur la
route et cela fait 48 heures que ces
ouvriers tentent de la déblayer
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qui se passe la paroi de la
montagne s'effondre ne restons pas là il
ya des pierres qui tombent encore
ça vaut vraiment la peine de prendre
autant de risques
tu sais il y a beaucoup d'argent à
gagner avec une mine mais c'est un peu
comme au casino on peut faire fortune en
peu de temps ou tout perdre dans la
montagne
bon allez moi je veut plus attendre je
passe quand même poussé vous gagnez
votre avis
tu crois que les problèmes sont finis
cette fois tout ce que je peux dire
c'est que sur cette route il ya juste la
place pour une voiture mais quelques
kilomètres plus loin
le sort s'acharne sur digoin les knicks
tu peux descendre s'il te plaît un peu
plus il ya encore un problème devant
cette fois ci c'est la route qui
s'effondre
[Applaudissements]
on doit pouvoir passer quand même ils
vont me guider
[Applaudissements]
oui
et les gars vous devriez creuser un peu
plus la montagne par la salle
éloignerait la voiture du bord du ravin
ça serait plus prudent allez tout le
monde en voiture
il reste encore une vingtaine de
kilomètres à parcourir
peu de kilomètres pour un long moment
d'enfer